el primer ministro armenio recorrió las
calles de ereván para dar un mensaje a
la población a pesar de la atención es
mejor no tener más enfrentamientos se le
escuchó decir a viva voz horas antes
desde su oficina acusó al ejército
armenio de un intento de golpe militar y
luego de que este último exigiera su
renuncia se tome la decisión de
destituir al primer sub jefe de estado
mayor de las fuerzas armadas tiran
khachatryan y al jefe del estado mayor
general ya he firmado todos los papeles
seguido de una declaración del estado
mayor en que los militares exigieron mi
renuncia
pajín han aceptado firmar un acuerdo de
paz en noviembre entre su país y
azerbaiyán el pacto negociado por rusia
puso fin a 44 días de combates en los
que el ejército azerbayano tenía una
clara ventaja sobre las fuerzas armenias
en el enclave de nagorno karabaj sobre
la actual tensión en armenia el kremlin
se pronunció hacemos un llamado a la
calma y creemos que la situación debe
permanecer en el ámbito constitucional
aún no ha habido contacto entre el
presidente putin y el primer ministro
armenio pero para un sector del ejército
armenio ponerle fin al conflicto de esta
manera significó una derrota inadmisible
luego de esto siguieron días de protesta
que pedían la renuncia de página ya que
azerbaiyán logró recuperar el control
sobre grandes partes del enclave
reconocido internacionalmente como parte
de su territorio pero que está poblado y
administrado principalmente por miembros
de la etnia armenia el acuerdo de paz
fue necesario para evitar que azerbaiyán
y invadir a todos
así como los militares la oposición
también ha pedido la destitución del
primer ministro quien dice que es mejor
la vida del diálogo en este conflicto
turquía respalda a azerbaiyán y ha
criticado a los copresidentes del
llamado grupo de minsk por no resolver
este conflicto que empezó ya hace
décadas
[Aplausos]